حقائب موظبه وصرر محموله على الراس احد
مخاوف السباعيه المحيطه بالسودان وليس
اكبرها كوابيس تتسرب عبر السدود وانابيب
المياه وتتمل بعتاد حركات مسلحه عبر
الحدود التي باتت بيئه اكثر خصوبه للتمرد
اجلس الانذار التي تدق اقليميا ودوليا لا
تنحصر بكون السودان ثالث اكبر دوله في
افريقيا بل انه يمتد عبر منطقه حيويه
جيوسياسيا غير مستقره وهشه ببعض اجزائها
مصر المتعطشه للمياه اكثر دوله عربيه
اكتظاظا بالسكان وتتشارك مع السودان
تاريخا من السياسه والتجاره والثقافه
ومياه النيل فضلا عن علاقات وثيقه بالجيشه
واكثر من اربعه ملايين سودانيين على
اراضيها واي اضطراب بالعمق الاستراتيجي
لمصر من شانه عرقله الجهود المشتركه
للتوصل لات بشان صد النهضه التهديد المائي
ليس فقط ما تشكله اثيوبيا بطموحاتها
الكهرومائيه فالمناوشات على الحدود غير
منقطعه اصلا وقد يتسبب النزاع بعوده
التوتر بمنطقه الفشجه الخصبه الحدوديه
المتنازع عليها
تشاد الجاره الغربيه الفقيره تحتضن بالاصل
نحو 400 الف نازح سوداني جراء صراعات
سابقه اضيف اليهم اكثر من عشرين الفا
مؤخرا القلق التشادينابع من مخاوف امتداد
الازمه لمناطق استقبلت اللاجئين ومعظمهم
من دارفور فتاريخ تشاد طويل مع ميليشيات
الجنجويد التي شكلت نواه قوات احمد تي
قلق مشابه يتكون غربا مرتزقه ومسلح
ميليشيات سودانيون عادوا الى بلادهم بعد
لعب دور نشط في الصراع الليبي هؤلاء على
معرفه جيده بالساحه الليبيه ومطاردتهم
داخليا قد ترميهم على الحدود مجددا اما
جنوب السودان الدوله التي استقلت حديثا
فمخاوفها تتمثل ببدء عرقله الروابط
اللوجستيه لتصريف انتاجها النفطي البالغ
170 الف برميلا يوميا عبء اقتصادي قد
تزيده سوءا عوده جماعيه لاكثر من 800 الف
لاجئ يستضيفهم السودان ازمه تتشاركها مع
اريتريا فمئه الفا من مواطنيها قد يضطرون
لحزم امتعتهم من جديد
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاع جاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات